Before I start, I want to mention my sponsor for this video.
Portuguese pod one Oh one pod one Oh one courses are among my favorite language
tools, especially for listening and shadowing.
Why not click the link in the description for a free account and give it a try.
I'm sure you've heard of the Portuguese language,
but I know that some of you have never heard of the Galician language,
but today I'm going to talk about Galician and its connection to Portuguese.
Galician is a member of the barrel romance branch of the romance language
family. It's spoken by around 2.4 million people. Most of them in Galicia.
Felicia is an autonomous region in Northwestern. Spain,
that borders Portugal to the South Galician is coefficient with Spanish in
Galicia and by Spanish. I mean,
Castilian Galician is a sister language of Portuguese with the two of them
sharing a common origin beginning and around the ninth century,
there was a romance language now referred to as Galicia and Portuguese though,
at the time, it was simply considered a form of vulgar Latin.
This language began diverging into distinct Galician and Portuguese languages.
During the 13th century,
the County of Portugal was originally part of the kingdom of Galicia,
which was part of the kingdom of Leyland,
but it became the independent kingdom of Portugal in the year, 1139.
And it began expanding its border southward while they seized territory from the
Moors as the [inaudible] progressed, naturally,
they brought their language with them towards the South in the year 1230 Lael,
including Galicia was incorporated into the crown of Casteel.
And they were incorporated into Spain in the year, 15, 16,
the varieties of Galicia and Portuguese spoken to the North in Galicia.
And those spoken to the South in Portugal began to gradually become more
distinct until they were eventually thought of as separate languages because
Galician and Portuguese are still so similar today and have a high level of
mutual intelligibility.
You may hear some people say that Galician is a dialect of Portuguese,
but that's not accurate because it makes it sound like Galician developed from
Portuguese. When in reality,
they both developed from the same medieval language referred to as Galician
Portuguese people really only say that Galician has a dialect of Portuguese
because Portuguese is the more well-known language, the more famous language.
So instead you could say that they are two varieties of the same language rather
than saying Galician is a dialect of Portuguese,
and indeed they are more similar than dialects of some languages are,
but they have separate standard languages.
And deletion is associated with a culture that's distinct from the Portuguese
and from their former colonies. In many cases,
these are the two factors that determine whether two similar ways of
communicating are dialects of a single language or distinct languages though.
There is no universal criteria for how to determine that there are very similar
in terms of grammar and vocabulary,
but there are lots of little differences in their phonology and orthography in
large part due to the influence of Castilian on Galician
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] they must reduce any mice
[inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible] does not show.
[Inaudible] Elisa. Uh, but I think was
[inaudible] present thing where Capella
[inaudible].
Numerous differences in the consonant sounds of Galician and Portuguese.
There's no Vogue sound in Galician though. There is in Portuguese,
in Galician B and V represent the same phoneme book as in Spanish
it's Bo or a voiced by labial fricative note that this happens in
Northern Portugal too. For example, the word for cowl in deletion,
in standard pronunciation at the beginning of a word like this,
it would be BA but the speaker on the recording seems to say it as a fricative
look, listen to the pronunciation on this Galician dictionary site Bucca
and in Portuguese.
Up the word for cave in deletion and in
Portuguese covert.
Note that this word is used slightly differently in Portuguese, meaning cavity,
cavern, or grave. Sometimes the difference is also reflected in writing,
for example, the word for edible in Galician and in Portuguese.
Another.
Difference in Portuguese S is pronounced Z between vowels,
but not in Galician. For example,
the word for house in Galician and in Portuguese,
the word for thing in Galician and in Portuguese
In Galician C represents a voiceless dental fricative before I N
E as in Spanish, for example,
the word for five in Galician and in Portuguese.
Seeing another.
One in Galician,
the diagraph C H is pronounced Chuck in Portuguese it's ship.
For example, the verb,
meaning to call in deletion and in Portuguese.
Shamara. Another difference.
The Galician rhotic consonant is like the Spanish one, a trill or a tap.
There is no guttural rhotic sound like in Portuguese, for example,
the word meaning rich in Galician and in Portuguese.
In.
Galicia, there are no phonemic nasal vowels.
There are vowels that become nasalized due to their surrounding environment.
In other words, they're next to a nasal consonant,
but there are no pairs of words that are distinguished by vowel mentality.
And Valdez.
Ality is not a part of Galician orthography the word for bread in deletion.
And in Portuguese here,
you can see that the nasal vowel that existed in Galicia and Portuguese has been
lost in Galician, but remains in Portuguese in Galician.
There's a nasal consonant.
Instead note that when N comes at the end of a word in Galician,
it's pronounced NA rather than nuh also notice the loss of the diphthong
the word for brother in Galicia.
Either mine or either mouth.
And in Portuguese you'd mail it among is the standard form and used in
Western dialect while either Mo is used in central and Eastern dialects.
It among seems more similar to Castilian,
had a model judging by its nasal consonant and lack of a diphthong you to Mo
retains the diphthong that is also found in Portuguese.
But when there's a diphthong in Galician,
there's no nasal whether a vowel or a consonant.
We can see this in numerous words,
such as the word for hand and the plural form, Hans in Galician.
Man, man's mouth mouse.
In Portuguese mountain mountain.
Some of the nouns in Portuguese with this nasal diphthong have a different
plural form, but in deletion,
the plural remains the same simply add S medium.
Mediums.
There are also cognates that have differences in nasal consonants,
like the differences in the following, determiners, the words for ah,
or one in Galician. Ooh.
Ooh.
And in Portuguese Wilmer the words for some in Galician.
Hm.
Aye. Aye. Aye.
Nope.
That the first pair of words in Galician is standard and the second pair is
dialectal. And now in Portuguese,
I'll go all the words for no, no.
As a determiner in Galician. Yeah.
[Inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
And in Portuguese pneuma,
here are a few other differences in pronunciation and orthography Galician uses
M with a Tilda and LL instead of NH and L H as in
Portuguese, for example,
the words for line in Galician and in Portuguese, Lena,
the word for red in Galician and in Portuguese for module,
you will notice that cognate words are often written with different vowel
accents or one will have a written accent. And the other won't for example,
the word for moon in Galician and in Portuguese
and the verb form, meaning I ate,
or I was eating in Galician and in Portuguese
Galician uses the letter X to represent the sound of HSA of voiceless post
alveolar fricative,
but Galician doesn't have a voice to post alveolar fricative Jew.
So you'll notice words with Azure sound in Portuguese being used in Galician
with a shutter sound represented by X, for example,
the word for people in Galician ended Portuguese.
The word for window in deletion and in Portuguese Chanel.
You'll also see some slightly different word forms. For example,
when prepositions contract with articles in Galician.
And.
In Portuguese building build up.
This combination of preposition plus article means by that or for the along
with some other meanings. Here's an example sentence,
meaning I did that for them.
And fishing East [inaudible].
I see a couple of other differences here as well.
Notice the different spelling of the demonstrative article,
meaning that also notice the different forms the verb takes in either language
fishin versus fees. Both are the first person,
singular prorate form of cognitive verbs,
Galician [inaudible] and Portuguese Farzad verbs often take the same
forms in both languages, but in this case,
they're a little different let's look at a somewhat bigger difference in verbs
in Galician, the past perfect tense isn't conjugated with an auxiliary verb.
Here's the sentence meaning the teacher had already arrived in Galician
word for word it's. The teacher already had arrived.
This verb form here is the third person singular PLU, perfect form.
Portuguese does actually have that same tense that is used in Galician,
but it's not used in spoken Portuguese.
[Inaudible].
Word for word it's. The teacher already had arrived here.
We can see that the past perfect is expressed with a compound tense.
The auxiliary verb is the first person singular imperfect form of, of ed,
which means have at least as an auxiliary verb,
it's followed by the masculine singular past participle love Chicago Galician
doesn't use compound tenses in general.
Simple tenses are usually used in their place. Pronouns,
Galician and European Portuguese pronouns are generally the same though.
There are some little differences in Portuguese.
The second person singular familiar pronoun is to add in Galicia nits
tea. And in Portuguese,
there is just one equivalent pronoun for both direct and indirect objects to
in Galician. There are two Tay and check in standard Galician. There are both,
but depending on the dialect,
many speakers use either tank for both direct object and indirect object or
Che for both direct object and indirect object.
Now let's look at some more example sentences and break them down.
These sentences mean Galician is a sister language of Portuguese in Portuguese.
He's Jewish and then Galician.
Oh, by LIGO [inaudible] word word it's.
The.
Galician is a language sister of the Portuguese.
Notice the difference in the indefinite article that we saw earlier,
notice that the Galician article has the letters N H which represent the sound.
No. While the Portuguese article simply has an M representing a sound
next, we see an acute accent marking the Portuguese word lingua,
but not in Galician. Next notice the differences in the word for sister,
similar to the words for brother that we saw earlier,
the Galician word has no nasal vowel yet notice the acute accent above the
letter. A we also see different diacritics over the words for Portuguese
diacritics in Galician are much simpler than in Portuguese.
Vowels can take only an acute accent,
which usually represents the primary stress of the word when it's not in the
default location in Portuguese,
the acute accent is used to show primary stress,
but only for low vowels while the circumflex indicates the equivalent high
vowel, then there is E which is always a high vowel,
but Grove accent is used to show the contraction of two side-by-side vowels.
Normally the preposition, ah, and an article or demonstrative pronoun.
And of course the Portuguese uses this symbol to indicate phonemic nasal vowels,
but this doesn't occur in Galatians.
One last thing to note in the sentence here,
we see that the combination of the preposition do or day and the definite
article, Oh, is the same in both languages.
Remember we saw some earlier that have different forms, but in this case,
they're the same one more pair of sentences.
These sentences mean I've been working for 12 hours in Portuguese
word for word it's. I am to work.
There is 12 hours and then Galena.
[Inaudible].
I take working 12 hours,
but the woman you hear in the video told me that it might be more natural for a
Galician to use the word for a dozen. Instead.
[Inaudible].
This pair of sentences. We see some more significant differences. First of all,
the way of expressing the present.
Perfect progressive meaning in either language is different in European
Portuguese, it would be like this with the present tense of the auxiliary verb,
meaning to be plus the infinitive of the main verb.
This is actually the present progressive form,
but it's often used where the present perfect progressive would be used in
English and in Brazilian Portuguese,
this would be the present participle rather than the infinitive here.
You see the first person singular present tense of the verb LVAD,
which means take though it is also used with the meaning of,
to spend time doing something it's followed by the present participle.
So the way it's expressed is like saying I spend 12 hours working in
Portuguese.
Levada is not really used in this way with the meaning of spend time doing let's
take a look at how that verb LVAD is conjugated in the present tense in both
languages to see how similar forms are.
You'll live to leverage your lever fossil
fuels level.
Notice that only the second and third person,
plural forms are slightly different. And in pronunciation,
the sound represented by V is different.
You can probably see why Galician and Portuguese share a very high degree of
mutual intelligibility. And by the way,
that's also true for Brazilian Portuguese,
even though the samples in the video were for European Portuguese. In fact,
some people say that Galician is closer to Brazilian Portuguese than it is to
European Portuguese or Galician and Portuguese varieties of a single language.
Well, linguistically they genuinely seemed similar enough that they could be
considered a single language. And as I mentioned before,
you could say that together, they form one plurry centric language,
one language with multiple standard varieties. But as I mentioned before,
it's often cultural or national identity that determines what is considered a
distinct language versus a variety of a language.
If history had taken a different turn and Galicia and Portugal today formed a
single country,
I'm sure that all Galician dialects and all Portuguese dialects would be
considered varieties of a single language.
Would it be called deletion or Portuguese or something else who knows the
question of the day to native speakers of Portuguese and Galician,
in your opinion,
do you speak varieties of a single language or do you speak different languages?
Why do you think so? And to other people disregarding cultural issues,
do you think they seem like different languages or varieties of a single
language? And this is the part of the video.
When I say thanks to my Patrion patrons,
especially it might talk to your patrons whose names appear on the screen.
I want to give a very special thanks to them and to everyone.
Thank you for watching and have a nice day.
Oh, you're still here. Okay. Well, here's one more pair of sentences for you.
These sentences mean I want to buy some clothes in Galician.
And in Portuguese.
Word for word, I want buy some clothes.
These sentences are quite similar,
but you can see that the word for buy is different.
The Galician word Medicard used to have the meaning of trade as in to buy and
sell goods. According to several dictionaries,
Medicard still exists in Portuguese with that meaning too, though.
It seems it's not commonly used anymore.
The Portuguese word [inaudible] is also used in Galician as a synonym of
Medicard.
We also see the slightly different determiners that we saw before Galician
and Portuguese. I'll go, man.